on passe au blind test
et aux platines j'accueille macias
héliporté
les bois
enfin
si oui est-ce que tu serais venu tout
seul ou quoi alors j'ai même tu es
beaucoup mieux tiré
oui nous sommes à l'époque de la
mondialisation mis d'accord oui
l'angleterre
oui
m
va dire le contraire
on les diffuser en entier on les dit
musée la cité les salles dans 87 pays
en inde aussi on a nous aussi un bon beh
oui je nie
à la réunion la saline royale
bonsoir mademoiselle joie bien sûr voilà
un garçon qui ne vient jamais les mains
vides
c'est bien philippe lortie normes
avioniques
en effet plusieurs des fans à m'appuyer
sur eux
cet apport pour avoir ton carnet
d'adressés ou alors vous connaissez le
principe du blind test mes amis j'ai eu
raison que tes lunettes maina parce que
c'est le moment pour écouter
oui c'est le moment important écoutons
nous absorbons je veux la terre prête
oui attention et on peut donner un
indice si les gens trouvent paris
c'était spécial italie c'est un
spécialité du chat bas il n'y ait pas de
fait c'est bien comme exemple ce qu'il
n'y ait pas ça tombe bien
si quelqu'un souffre ici le pré va la
cua et si quelqu'un ose souffle la croix
aouina la rédaction barzotti il est
belge et non la nive y est pas faisons
jamais d'erreurs dans le blanc des yeux
mais jamais alors attention lors ont tué
près si on est vraiment et me fit wii
guy a lepage qui va présenter une
émission au québec qui va s'appeler on
va pas
le roi du monde
taris attention
je pense entre le mas landman on se
concentre mes enfants monsieur du buzz
attention philippe morceau numéro un je
veux
je vais te dire un blind test de chlore
fille c'est ce qu'ont les mecs qui sont
kamikazes quand ils sont fait sauter
pour l'islam
ils ont droit à ça voilà c'est sont
vierges
ouais elles sont bien sûr on vérifiera
tiré à huy jean philippe alors numéro un
donc c'est laurent baffie qui marque le
point comme d'hab' à toi philippe numéro
deux puis
j
andrea bocelli
merde c'est lui qui le dit
pavarotti en
erreur bobo mauvaise idée
delon
oui
j'ai dit
je sais pas
jamais
alors ça fait quoi pour l'équipe de
laurent baffie c'est bien ça y est nous
sommes arrivés au point pour l'équipe de
marina foïs
de quoi vous le vivez lambin fille mais
c'est pas grave tu peux te rattraper
marina on a dit on est déjà dans tous
nos chanteurs italiens ont des
associations il est au fond mon cerveau
faut qu'ils reviennent on va revenir
attention philippe que je ne fais plus
rien
je pas été arrêté
non
le tir est paru en france
je crois je crois que c'est albano et
romina peau
et la fille de tyrone power qui
s'appelle romina power
absolument mais on n'avait pas d'idée
chercher un non seulement on n'a pas vu
les duos non mais c'est connu ça non oui
c'est connu non retrouvées on a le point
va là puisque ça a été trouvée la banane
le poids va là elle ne l'a pas souffler
à le point là du côté où ça a été trouvé
ma ba oui oui ça date a été géré bon
d'accord
c'est très dur et se dessine en temps
c'est logique c'est moi qu'ils aient
trouvé là au sénat attention continue
on
à monthey
le tu es
pendant
à qui tu donnes le point à bas prix ou à
marina
moi aussi je rêvais à marina tu vois
c'est marrant attention philippe qu
aucun cadeau
d'ici lundi
alors
à
lee
biens sociaux foutu nieuviarts c'est
comme le 7 à la boule à un moment donné
ça commence ce sens et des tensions
philippe
non
3 3 c'est très bagarrer ce soir 3 me 3,3
pour qui le [ __ ] et populaire fjep
alors acheter ils essayent de nous
devons de les titrer avec thomas c'est
un producteur mais c'est bien tu sais
moi que c'est un producteur je suis sur
ton à pain de poupon ah non mais il y en
a 1 2 par le contest
il
lee
orlando exige le clip thierry roland sur
scène d'origine italienne carré bah oui
bah oui alors valide alors je viens
dirigé chanson italienne c'est peut être
un américain alors baphuon devront le
demander les dates quand c'est comme ça
je me sors pas trop mal c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas possible
voilà près de cinq ans 4 oui madame
pascal bataille ce soir non j'adore ce
jeu dans cette riche en europe
oui
tettey
j'adore ça là on l'a pas aussi ni la
solitudine que devient on continue
philippe corti madame honeywell
buffy impérial 6 courts baffie pas pour
l'équipe ii bat fille parce que c'est
vrai que momo et d un peu quand même
oui série 3 pour l'équipe de marina foïs
franck dubosc et notre ami thomas
langmann qui a plus de succès avec
double zéro rachid will un prénom mais
il a retrouvé reçus dans un autre et je
conçois mais n'a aucune chance d'être
gérée on va me la passe qu'il n'ya pas
frédéric françois je peux te dire dans
le green tech rappelons la reine thierry
rappelons la règle ils peuvent jouer
aussi ils peuvent jouer c'est bien sûr
ils ont le droit de dire des trucs plus
important de le dire
attention corti
mary jane
aj dressions bracci mais bon un jour ce
coulage de gaz elle connaît un match où
on a visionné mon père n'a pas les
traits non là c'est parce qu'il ya là
les primes à monbalen sa soeur mélina
mélina jeudi clément nadia d'accord
merci
après voilà d'accord on continue
aujourd'hui d'attention numéro
messi
alors grâce à thomas landman on est à 6
1,6 pour l'équipe de laurent 28,5 pour
l'équipe de marina police alors on
continue
attention corti
bien sûr là et à un moment donné faut
s'arrêter c'est plus un jeu c'est
l'humiliation et des alliances est
annoncé alors là la voilà la fin du par
équipes on est à 6 6 ce qui veut dire
que l'équipe de laurent l équipe de
marina font match nul et la france
contre la croatie jeudi dernier un jury
vient le muay abl ouais
heureusement qu'on n'enregistre pas le
jeudi parce qu'on aurait raté mon agent
était bizarre non heureusement que les
jambes directs ont placé la force du
bien par la magie du direct peut rien
dire sur les anglais et non mais les
anglais sont très bien ils ont battu le
record des italiens seront bouchés le
champagne on a perdu à lille c'est plus
par équipes onassis et maintenant on
passe au chacun pour sa gueule
ok j'y vais attention il ya eu d'amis et
puis l'équipe 1 c'est clair donc
maintenant c'est chacun pour soi
corti à toi pour le bon touriste cas
désolé
et eux
laval a battu le mc aveugle en prélude à
bangui
tours
honneur
john's
à la bonne heure
je lui reconnais que les voix et les
paroles d'ailleurs ses fans il ya bon
effet gagné d'origine aviaire
je crois que le point légal parce que
pagny paye ses impôts en italie donc je
pense que ça va tomber à temps les cas
sylvain cardine tendu
il avait une barbe à un gore cette
chanson we et voudrais que tu passes la
révélation un petit peu plus longtemps
katrina d'or qu'est ce que oui mais moi
je suis fille de me dire les quatre
filles montent alors c'est la chef
casser la chaîne voilà c'est tout
non
moment je joue
g
au regard donc le bon qu aulas l'a été
remporté par mr assis et voilà il s'est
même pas vrai lui au début
enfin ce super banco c'est très très
très difficile non je pense que
peut-être agathe godard peut trouver
parce que c'est notre époque shea
c'est l'époque où on écoutait des trucs
comme ça craint vas-y même la radio tard
henry blanco
alors vous venez voir m
il a dit bobby solo il a dit oui
m
pour
que
oui
c'est un spécial rebeu parce que le
premier c'est la chine le deuxième je me
ramène vraiment la discrimination
faciale chez les rebeus qui viennent
piquer les bons côtés français je sais
alors on passe au méga bourgault radio à
c'est hyper dur jusqu'au l'ultra bon
comme et façon tu trouveras pas cherche
pas c'est très très dur
corty
là
gagarine a affirmé l'allemand
non
pourquoi tallinn italienne il a dit plus
claudia cardinale j'allais sophia loren
a duré plus d'une très belle et j'adore
ça le mec il a quand même été il a quand
même été au grand banditisme pendant des
années ce qui est bien donc c'est une
sophia loren et là je vois que ça fait
quand même deux pour momo un mot le
turbulent qui marque deux points à un
moment le boxeur qui marque deux points
et lorient est maintenant à ultra banco
la personne qui trouve ça repart avec
toutes les filles et repart et toutes
les filles non franchement je pensais je
ja alors attention tout le monde est
bien concentré c'est très très très
difficile moi j'ai du mal agathe tu dois
trouver sa merde
elle dort voilà non il tarde pas et
semir attention aux filles
mais le maire
énormes tubes dans les années 60
secteur mobile
habitant la ville il a dit je ne suis
pas un sou lambinon
j'étais vieux
moi
oui
c'est bien comme jacques martin le
dimanche
jacques borde a été construit voilà là
laurent tu es un dieu vivant
merci dieu existe il est sur le plateau
ce soir si bon merci mon avis
donc à l'issue dé chacun pour sa gueule
rachid un mot mode de beaux moments et
les vues difficiles est qu'ils en
pensent et parlent en asie celle ultra
méga bongo voilà parce que le monde est
injuste
alors on ne va pas dire non on dit
maintenant pourquoi alors on pense à toi
tu veux dire papa thierry dans
l'ambiance
parce que la vie est injuste laurent bal
des médias bamboo tout ça pourri c'est
quand même calibre ce second co ou
franchement c'est chacun pour sa gueule
parce que la vie est injuste laurent
alors la moins bien fait que des matchs
et d'un film aurait fait de le faire
après ça nous a bloqués quand tu sais
pas ça passe bien c'est par un montage
plus en tout cas c'est terminé tiré à
oui j'étais toujours dans l'émission et
il ne reste plus qu'une après c'est la
quille border sassetti c'est vrai que
c'était l'avant-dernière c'est la pire
pour la dernière c'est la dernière
ah ouais l'avant dernière c'est de la
merde elle était pas vrai bien
d'ailleurs est pour une main non non je
trouve avant de revenir lors on était
pas mal
et pour commencer l'année prochaine oui
non
voilà c'était comme au bar
et aussi pour ses amis américains les
magritte m6 termine de kate
victoria abril pense toujours que jeanne
labrune en et vitoria briller jean
pierre darroussin et si le 28 juillet et
10 avril de shit
la marraine de l'association empannage
africa michel mouillot foulée chez
michel lafon comme du beurre au secours
j'ai 30 ans le marie-anne chazel et
ponts du boss
javan
nathalie corré ça sort le 23 juin comme
du beurre romantique prend plus
à partir d'une question septembre au
bataclan jusqu'au 5 janvier
et à partir du 5 janvier en tournée dans
toute la france compte du besoin
saddam pacs black cats blog chez
hachette littératures alexandre ab
l'odyssée américaine c'est chez grasset
marina foïs
je me sens pas belle de bernard jeanjean
avec marina foïs et julien boisselier le
fameux julien boisselier
c'est le casse croûte le 4 août mais la
fois la marraine de la 9e édition de la
fête du cinéma
les 27 juin encore kool and the gang
l'album s'appelle de vie depuis l'audit
et le single s'appelle fraîche et ils
sont les 9 et 10 juillet à l'olympia à
gap les dar el kadar merckx dans la jet
set
chez michel lafon ça sort le 1er juillet
voilà et quand hugh grant est mon ami
monsieur gentil voilà
c'est étrange chat